-Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
I'm so happy that you're here.
-Me too. Very exciting.
-I'm a fan.
It's your first time
on our show.
-Yes.
-I want to get to know you.
I want to ask you -- you're
from Cuba, is that correct?
-Yeah.
-And did you start acting there?
-I did.
I went to drama school
when I was 14.
That was like, four years
of theater school.
-Yeah.
-And when I was on my second
year, I did my first movie.
I auditioned for it
and I got it,
and the teachers
were not very happy
and they told me
if I did the movie,
I was going to --
[ Clicks tongue ]
get kicked out of school.
-Of acting school?
-Yeah, because, you know...
-Wait.
This is kind of the goal, right?
-Well, if you do a movie,
you're not going to school.
So...
-I understand, yeah.
-I still did it, though.
-That's right.
Look at you now.
Come on. Yeah, exactly right.
[ Applause ]
-So they made me repeat
the year.
-Oh, really? They did?
-It was worth it.
-Yeah. Oh, good. Yeah.
I also heard something that you
used to hitchhike to school.
-Yeah. Didn't you?
-No. No. That's very dangerous.
I don't hitchhike.
-No, it's not in Cuba.
I mean, you just get there
faster than just --
-I understand, yeah, but...
-I will get there faster
than you, maybe.
-Yes, you will. Yeah.
Because no one
would pick me up.
If we're both on the street
with our thumb out,
they're gonna pick you up
and not me.
-Well, I didn't
do the thumb thing.
I'd just go to the stoplight,
so the cars have to stop.
-You would just jump into
strangers' cars,
like, "Take me to school"?
-Pretty much.
-Yeah?
-You just go to the window.
I'm like, "Hey, can you go
to the next stoplight?"
-No, this is too dangerous.
Oh no, no.
-No, it's not. I mean,
everyone's very used to it.
It's like free carpool.
-Any children watching,
don't do this.
But is that how you
ended up in the Bond movie?
Because you're from --
No, no, no! Not hitchhiking.
Not hitchhiking.
Being from Cuba, sorry.
-"Hey."
"Hi, do you guys mind
if I'm in this movie?"
-"Do you go to London?"
-"Can I be in the new
007 movie?"
"Sure. Come on."
No, but is it
because you're from Cuba?
Is that how?
-I mean, something
to do with that.
I think...
-You're so good in this,
by the way.
I told you backstage,
but I really mean it.
-Thank you.
-You get a giant laugh.
I'm not going to spoil
anything for anyone.
I won't ever do that.
but dude.
This one scene,
it's just beautiful to look at.
I go, it's it's iconic,
It's iconic.
-Thank you.
-You did, you crushed it.
You're fantastic.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Do you want to describe
who you play? Your 00 agent?
-Yeah, I play Paloma.
She's a CIA agent in Cuba.
-She's there to assist Bond
in his mission.
And she very excited
about the job.
-Yeah, yeah. You really are.
-She's very, very happy,
and like, you know, also nervous
because it's her first job,
big, big job.
-Yeah, you're like --
I could say the line.
You're like,
"Oh, I'm only three weeks
in training on the job."
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-The funny thing is that
I also had only
three weeks training,
so I think I just kept saying it
so much that Cary was like,
"Just say it. It's fine."
-Oh, because that's real life.
-"Just keep it."
-You just came from doing
a Marilyn Monroe movie
right to this.
-Yeah.
-Was that difficult to go
from that extreme to this?
-Yeah. Well...yeah.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
Marilyn did not train at all.
-No. Yeah, no.
-Like Paloma.
I mean, it was, it's like
opposite things, you know?
I did Marilyn,
it was a very intense,
and then I finished shooting
on a Friday.
I got on a plane on a Saturday
and I started shooting Bond
on Monday.
So I just remember
being on set like,
my first scene and I kind of
like started whispering
and Cary was like, "Mmm.
No, we're here now."
"You're in this movie now."
-This movie now.
-[ As Marilyn Monroe ]
"Happy birthday."
"No, we're not doing that now.
We're doing this."
-Kind of.
-We're doing this movie now.
Daniel Craig.
you guys are great together.
Is it odd that
you were in "Knives Out"
and then you're with Bond?
You guys are
a traveling team now.
-[ Laughing ]
-You go together.
-Yeah, that was awesome.
I mean, "Knives Out,"
it was such a special movie.
We had so much fun,
and Daniel and I
were together all the time.
We were this team.
But back then,
only Daniel was talking
about Bond and his training.
I had no idea what was
going to happen.
-That you were gonna be in it?
-No, no.
That happened,
like, four months later.
-He's phenomenal, man.
-It was a
very happy coincidence.
-I loved the movie
top to bottom.
I'm a big fan of all the movies,
but this one has everything
you could even think about.
Action, you know,
suspense, spy thriller thing,
love story.
-Humor.
It's emotional,
but also it's real stunts.
It's not just like a CGI thing,
which, you know, is fine.
This is like, real
human beings doing crazy stunts.
You're like, "What?"
I've never seen anything like
that one motorcycle thing.
-It is spectacular, really.
-It's a movie.
It's just like, wow, they made
an unbelievable movie.
-You really like it.
-I loved it.
I loved it. It was so good.
I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here's Ana de Armas in
"No Time to Die." Take a look.
[ Gunfire ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
That is what I'm talking about!
That exact scene!
You're amazing. Ana de Armas!